produire de l'énergie en particulier
l'électricité nous avons une chance à
notre modèle historique
le parc installé
de nucléaire le nucléaire notre modèle
historique emmanuel macron charles de
gaulle deux présidents deux époques et
un même discours celui de la
souveraineté énergétique produire de
l'électricité grâce à l'atome c'est
possible depuis les années 50 en france
à l'époque le site de marcoule dans le
gard est choisi pour une expérimentation
voici dévoilé au public les aspects de
cette réalisation qui fait entrer la
hausse dans le cycle de l'utilisation
industrielle de l'atome le 28 septembre
1956 ça y est pour la première fois la
france réussit à fabriquer de
l'électricité grâce à l'atome la france
est donc le premier pays de l'europe
continentale de l'ouest à produire de
l'électricité à partir d'une centrale
atomique
deux ans plus tard en 1958 le général de
gaulle se rend en personne sur le site
de marcoule sa visite commentée à la
télé est un enjeu politique écoutez le
ton du journaliste de l'époque très
patriotique c'est ici le germain de la
puissance d'un pays dans l'ordre
industriels comme dans l'ordre militaire
et c'est cette promesse pierre boulez
marqué le général de gaulle en disant il
est saisissant des constater ce que sont
les réalisations en fais quand on s'en
donne la peine
les années passent le général de gaulle
continue de faire la tournée des
centrales en construction ou déjà
achevés septembre 1963 direction le site
nucléaire du tricastin dans la drôme
pour lui ça ne fait aucun doute
l'énergie de demain elle viendra du
nucléaire nous avons décidé d'avoir ce
qu'il nous faut et d'autant mieux est
d'autant plus que cette puissance
nucléaire comme on dit est liée
directement à
l'énergie atomique elle même qui est
comme vous le savez tous
le font de l'activité de demain
quatre ans plus tard en 1967 une tient
exactement le même discours nogent ce
genre
une part
pour un développement industriel un
développement nouveau de l'énergie
et par conséquent du progrès après de
gaulle la politique nucléaire continuera
d'être au coeur des enjeux électoraux de
georges pompidou à emmanuel macron à six
mois de la présidentielle le président a
annoncé vouloir investir un milliard
d'euros d'ici 2030 dans les smr des
petits réacteurs nucléaires
[Musique]